do you think um Comedians and musicians
in some deep fundamental way are made
from the same cloth like are they
spiritually connected somehow I think
everyone's connected spiritually in the
same way so I think personality-wise
um Comedians and musicians are quite
different actually oh in what
way well you you'd have to subdivide
even musicians into different categories
too because you know the thing that I
appreciate about comedians is that you
know you go to a restaurant with them
and like all the observational humor of
like they'll just they'll notice
everything and make you laugh about it
which a really great songwriter does the
same thing too and my favorite lyricists
like Leonard Cohen Bob Dylan Paul Simon
they you know Warren zon they add comedy
into their lyric and like so those types
of people I would liken to hanging out
with a comedian it's very different from
like say somebody that is an
instrumental guitarist or something like
that that they're they're more focused
on whether it's like a kinesthetic thing
or like a physical thing or whatever it
is they're not they're not quite doing
the observational thing in the same way
so I just appreciate like my favorite
thing to do is go out and laugh
especially cuz like I can tend to be
pretty analytical and be in my head um
and so anything that just kind of lets
me be in my heart and just enjoy life I
think there's a photo of you with de
Chappelle on stage what was that about
so right after Leonard Cohen passed away
The Comedy Store threw me a birthday
party it was this crazy lineup and like
it was like I'd play a song with my band
and um and then Jackson Brown sat in and
like sung a song and then like Dave
Chappelle came up and said some jokes it
was like it was like one of my favorite
nights ever yeah yeah it was cool it was
it was a very healing birthday party
yeah there's something magical about
that place yeah it's really special yeah
well the mothership has some magic to it
too it's really cool it's different
totally different vibe but like super
awesome